/ Hey, Google Developers
Live, I'm Zachary Cohn.
I work with an organization
called Startup Weekend.
And I'm here today
with Don Dodge.
And we're here to give you pitch
advice for startups and
entrepreneurs.
So Don is a developer
and startup
advocate here at Google.
And he's a veteran of five
different startups, so he's
had some experience pitching.
And he's going to be here to
help us with that today.
So Don, are all pitches
the same, or are
there different types?
DON DODGE: No, there are
different types of pitches.
There's the elevator pitch,
which is the shortest one.
And the elevator pitch is used
to get the next meeting with
an investor or with a partner.
The next pitch is usually about
30 minutes long, and
that goes into more of what the
product is, how it works,
what problem it solves.
And then there's an hour-long
pitch, which is for investors
where you go deep
into the product
and all of the details.
So I think today we want to talk
about the elevator pitch
and why that's important.
ZACHARY COHN: Cool.
Well, tell me about the
elevator pitch.
What makes a good one?
DON DODGE: An elevator pitch
should be five minutes or less
and it should cover
just a few topics.
What you want to do is get
their head nodding yes.
If you don't see their head
nodding yes, stop, because
you're probably not going
to get very far.
And you need to redo
your pitch.
So the very first thing that you
do in an elevator pitch is
explain what is the problem
you're solving.
And the investor or the partner
or the customer, needs
to identify with that problem.
If they're not interested in
the problem you're solving,
then they're not interested at
all in your solution to it.
So one big mistake that a lot
of entrepreneurs make is, in
their elevator pitch, they
immediately jump into their
solution and why it's better.
And if you haven't gotten the
person to nod their head and
understand what the problem
is, there's no way they're
going to be interested
in your solution.
So that's the number
one thing.
Start with what problem
you solve.
Try to use a real-life example
of a real person that you
know, or a real life
example of the
problem that you're solving.
The second thing you do
is talk about why is
this problem important.
Why are you solving
this problem?
And again, if you have real-life
experience where
you've experienced this
problem, and you're
passionate about it.
Then that's going to get the
credence that says, OK, this
guy knows what he's
talking about.
I'm going to listen.
So those are the first
two things.
Start with the problem.
Start with, why this problem
is important And what
experience you have
in solving it.
If you don't have experience in
solving the problem, then
they're going to say, well,
yeah, interesting problem, but
you don't know anything
about it.
So start with those things.
ZACHARY COHN: Interesting.
So what are some good ways
to practice pitching?
DON DODGE: Well, you don't want
to practice on the people
who are going to
give you money.
You want to have practice
with other people.
So practice with your friends
first because they'll be kind.
Then practice with people you've
worked with in the
past, or people who are in
this industry and kind of
understand the problem, and see
if you can get them to nod
their heads.
Then move on to investors
and that kind of thing.
ZACHARY COHN: Cool.
Well, how would you
structure a pitch.
We talked a little bit about
that, but could we go into
more detail about the different
things that you
should have in, what you should
say first, what you
should say later on?
DON DODGE: So there are
three main things
in an elevator pitch.
The problem that you're solving,
your solution, and
the team that you have that
can solve that problem.
Those three things.
So again, start with the
problem you're solving.
If they nod their head like,
yeah, I understand that
problem, I've seen that, then
move on to your solution.
What is your solution?
Why is it better than what
exists out there today?
And then close with the team,
and why this team is capable
of putting together
this solution.
If you cover those three things
in a minute to a minute
and a half, now you have
permission to go deeper.
If you don't see them nodding
their head at those three
things, stop and move
on to the next one.
ZACHARY COHN: Great.